the Food and Drug Administration has
approved the first generic rival to
EpiPen the self injecting device used to
treat potentially life-threatening
allergic reactions has faced a number of
issues in recent years including
shortages and notoriously high prices
and a Warner reports on how the new
generic drug sold by Teva
Pharmaceuticals could shake up the
market it kind of does scare 11-year old
Sam Bronson is like millions of
Americans he suffers from a severe nut
allergy which means having an EpiPen
like this one could be a matter of life
or death but in May the FDA reported a
shortage of epi pens due to a
manufacturing issue demand left many
pharmacies bare the shortages is a
really big problem it didn't matter who
I called I could not find it parents
like Sam's mother Megan Brunson have
been stocking up on epi pens as the
back-to-school season begins
Brunson finally tracked one down but
then ran into another problem it's about
$700 or just shy of $700 for one box and
I really needed to have the generic the
drug maker Milan faced backlash after
the price of its EpiPen soared from just
over 100 dollars in 2009 to more than
$600 in 2016 the company put out a
cheaper $300 version following criticism
from Congress
Tavi pharmaceuticals will make the new
generic EpiPen but it's unclear when it
will be available or exactly how much it
will cost in a statement the company
said we're applying our full resources
to this important launch in the coming
months and are eager to begin supplying
the market dr. Jon LaPook is the CBS
News chief medical correspondent you
don't want price to have to come into
that to decide well you know what I
would have had this life-saving
medication with me but it was just too
expensive and for the Brunson family
that's a decision they face every day it
is just not even feasible for a
household income who no matter who you
are to write over a check for $700 for
CBS this morning and a Werner and I'm
saying